premier souvenir
ma première ivresse ah bon
[Applaudissements]
au cinéma dans le film de Chabrol ce qui
veut dire cannamo glalis joue dans le
film Chabrol vous êtes très bien très
belle et on a eu tout de suite envie de
vous inviter en voyant le film oui ça me
fait alors votre agent Jean-François
Gabart dites-vous chaque fois qu'elle
entre dans mon bureau j'ai l'impression
de voir Silvana Mangano
pitbull toi
aussi vous avez une voix italienne un
peu cassée comme ça
parce que vous êtes grec en fait c'est
pour ça que j'ai la voix casser alors
votre agent qui vous aime bien ça va
c'est votre agent en même temps il vous
vend il dit anna est à des années
lumières des autres comédiennes de sa
génération
allez bon allez super faut le garder
Jean-François gabarre alors vous avez 22
ans vous avez fait trois films terminale
de francis Giraud qui a pas été non plus
il faut le dire
succès du ciel
non non
la captive de Chantal Ackerman qui a eu
plus de succès en tous les cas qui a été
à bien apprécié par la par la critique
et maintenant merci pour le chocolat
donc de Claude Chabrol avec Isabelle
Huppert et Jacques Dutronc bon Anna vous
êtes avec moi attendez vous savez pas
vous faire draguer par gunters
[Musique]
oh là là tu as de la musique il faut le
trouver ça quand même en fait vous
saviez pas du tout jouer du piano vous
êtes obligé d'apprendre c'était
l'horreur non c'était c'était bien moi
ça m'a permis de me concentrer vraiment
j'avais un travail très rigoureux à
faire
vous aimez bien les contrats quel signe
pour voir comme ça
je suis tôt
toroscope
très très bien mais pas pour se marier
ça va très bien
pour draguer le son il fait vous êtes
taureau ah ben moi je suis scorpion
les statistiques 95% des Tauros
scorpions c'est des amours
bien et alors sur le tournage comment
s'est passé avec Claude Chabrol sympa
trop tôt on se couche pas trop
tardes qu'on peut se faire sur un
tournage dans la maison de David Bowie
au lac Léman au bord du lac Léman qui
n'arrive pas à vendre vous connaissez
cette maison vous
maison de David Bowie n'arrive pas à la
vendre parce qu'elle donne pas sur le
lac en fait ils en demandent 16 millions
je vous le dis donc il y a du pognon si
ça vous intéresse si elle aime la Villa
elle peut vous offrir
[Applaudissements]
c'est la stratégie inverse Giroud il
aurait dit tu verras on va faire des
économies on va mettre beaucoup d'argent
de côté et un jour on ira en vacances à
Madère et
Gunter il dit 16 millions s'il y en a un
envie il y a pas de problème ou tu vas à
toi et la semaine dernière
vous êtes tous enrhumé ou quoi bien
c'est votre passion vous est venu
comment c'est à dire comment vous avez
découvert que vous aviez envie de faire
ce métier
j'adorais aller au cinéma ou peut-être
aussi mes parents m'y emmenaient assez
régulièrement et non c'est plutôt quand
j'ai commencé
à aborder des problèmes plus
philosophiques que ça m'a semblé
important de faire cette chose il faut
savoir attention sur
pourquoi pas
elle a fait elle a fait hippocaille et
tout non tu vois
non non c'est vrai
vous avez voulu faire mannequin parce
que ça vous
adoué en fait pourquoi vous arrivez pas
à prendre les pauses
c'est presque ça disons que j'avais des
idées préconçues très pesantes et j'ai
toujours eu peur d'avoir l'herbe bête et
je pensais que là c'était vraiment le
décor idéal donc non non non
c'est une culture qu'on nous fait vite
mais moi j'ai rencontré des défis
absolument formidables quand j'ai fait
ça qui parlait trois quatre cinq langues
couramment alors qu'elles avaient à
peine 20 ans enfin mais moi j'y arrivais
pas j'y arrivais pas mon voyage je
m'ennuyais sur les photos
Jacques demyle passage de la Pommeraie
tout ça donc c'est une ville déjà
cinéaste avant même de commencer un jour
vous venez à Paris
et puis voilà puis après bon vous avez
fait des petits boulots et puis jusqu'au
jour où conservatoire avec mes SGUI si
on vous a choisi pour faire ce film ça
s'est passé assez facilement finalement
j'ai pas fait de crise depuis assez
longtemps
mais c'est vrai ou pas si tes
problématique plutôt pour mes parents
mais j'ai pas fait ça si souvent que ça
j'ai rêvé que votre frère était enceinte
et vais tuer sa progéniture c'est un peu
non
j'en ai beaucoup parlé mais vous avez vu
non toujours pas pourquoi
cette folie en vous et que c'est ça qui
vous permettra d'être une grande actrice
non non j'ai beaucoup de curiosité
par rapport à la psychanalyse je vais le
faire mais j'ai pas encore eu l'occasion
de rencontrer quelqu'un vous supportez
pas les hommes qui rentrent là je le dis
alors oui si vous justement c'est
important si vous voulez pas lancer un
appel vous non ça va très bien sur le
plan amoureux parce que vous savez
qu'ici ça marche incroyablement
mais c'est vrai non mais c'est vrai il y
a déjà 4 5 couples qui se sont formés
ici grâce à grâce à moi a commencé par
la Rousseau
la Russo a rencontré Fabrice grâce à un
appel que nous avons lancé dans cette
émission
ça va oui oui ça va et vous gui ça va
très bien ben oui ça va tous les deux
[Rires]
on va pas faire ça
bon donc vous
il y a pas de problème vous avez dit un
truc toute façon qui va en calmer
beaucoup vous avez dit les hommes d'un
soir ne m'intéressent pas
ouais
histoire sérieuse romantique avec
beaucoup d'échanges beaucoup de
discussions
c'est ça c'est bien c'est mais des fois
ça fait du bien aussi
je vais essayer
elle a fait hypocogagne tu vois donc
c'est une autre culture bon Anna on va
on va mieux vous connaître on va faire
une interview
[Musique]
pourquoi tu fais ça
fait trois semaines qui se prépare pour
cette émission il la regarde le match le
moment venu après
le meilleur élève
si j'avais été un article quand tu étais
au centre de formation je me suis occupé
spécialement aujourd'hui
vous êtes concentré
premier souvenir
ma première ivresse ah bon
premier
quand j'ai récité une poésie dans dans
ma classe c'était en CE2 ça vous a plu
vous a dit c'est ça que je veux faire
maintenant pas vraiment enfin j'ai eu
une part monstrueuse
premier mensonge
c'est
pas mal le mensonge ça permet d'inventer
une réalité meilleure je crois que je
pratiquais très tôt
premier péché
il y a pas de péché
[Applaudissements]
rien n'est péché rien n'est pêché
premier amour
il faut que je dise quoi
vous dites il avait je sais pas voilà
quand c'est peu tu étais petit j'imagine
c'était un garçon blond avec une queue
de cheval comme ça qui baisse devant mon
collège vous êtes sûr c'est un garçon
premier baiser
sur un skateboard
premier flirt poussé
avec la langue et tout ça
ah oui mais c'était le premier
idole
Aznavour peut-être
première belle robe
j'avais une robe en lapin que ma famille
c'est celui de Nantes
[Applaudissements]
je vais pas vous demander la première
fois à 3 parce qu'ici non parce que ici
on est ici on est discret donc je
demanderai pas la première fois trois
premières fois 4
[Applaudissements]
première rupture
première rupture c'était à 18 ans
votre premier pétard parce que ça c'est
de la provocation facile première ligne
premier succès
premier succès mais c'est là c'est là
tout le monde
[Rires]
bon première échec je le connais c'est
terminal de Giraud
première chose que vous faites le matin
au réveil je prends ma douche
je c'est un truc que je fais c'est
inconscient j'ai vu ça dans un film
c'est la TV
je me bats la main j'ai un grand short
comme ça de foudre et je me passe la
main
après je vois mon café
tu as aucune chance aucune chance non
mais avec Anna
mais c'est inconscient c'est souvent on
fait ça dernière volonté si vous deviez
mourir là maintenant
c'est important de devenir un ange
devenir un ange ah bon c'est tout c'est
pas plus chaud que ça mais c'est très
chaud
on est tous des anges des artistes ici
ce soir tout le monde est déjà et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu